right now we have um
$6,200 um on a credit card okay $7,000
on a truck and then a
$20,000 home equity line of credit okay
um within the past since August we've
paid off $34,000 in credit card debt
good so we're we're on a roll um and my
goal is to have the credit card and the
truck paid off by March do I not pay on
the home well I pay the minimum payment
on the home equity line of credit do our
three to six months emergency savings
and then when we sell our house pay that
off and still have 20% to put down on
the new house I'd pay it off I'd work to
pay it off for two reasons a it's less
than half of the value of your home I'm
guessing yeah we owe 124 on our house
and we could sell it for 230 yeah
because it's less than half of that 124
I'd go ahead and pay it off and here's
the thing if you don't pay it off it's
going to cut into your your winnings
right when you sell the house